attention au kayak polo il ya contact la
mise en jeu résume la discipline en plus
d'être un bon kayakistes le poloïste
doit être explosif endurant et surtout
adroit avec le ballon deux équipes de
cinq joueurs s'affrontent sur un plan
d'eau d'une trentaine de mètres pendant
deux périodes de dix minutes ils peuvent
se passer le ballon à la main ou à la
pagaie mêmes dribbler c'est un peu comme
round où tous les joueurs sont à la fois
défenseur est à la fois attaquant après
chacun ses préférences et ses positions
on a des commandes on a des ailiers en
généralisé lié ce sont les plus rapides
et les centraux c'est plutôt les dégâts
les plus costauds et ceux qui tiennent
bien leur bateau qui sont bien que ce
soit arrivé en france en 1984 il kayak
un vrai sport de contact à tout moment
le porteur de balle peut être poussé à
l'eau par l'adversaire c'est d'ailleurs
l'un des aspects les plus spectaculaires
de la discipline qui fait des poloïstes
et spécialiste de l'esquimautage express
techniques permettant de remettre le
bateau à l'endroit en quelques secondes
oui on a des cascades grille donc à des
coups de pagaie parfois assez rarement
sur le visage mais bon même un ballon
sur le nez ça fait pas de bien mais
c'est vrai que c'est un jeu très
physique on a des bateaux adaptés avec
des mousses à l'avant à l'arrière et
gillet renforcée sur les côtés qui
permettent de nous protéger de les côtes
cette saison quatre vingts équipes
pratiquer le kayak polo dans l'hexagone
de son côté trappe se bat pour son
maintien en nationale 4